foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar preparing
for the worst the Resurgence of
respiratory infections
I'm Cassie saltman of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by diasaurin molecular LLC
to learn more visit
molecular.dsaurin.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Dr
Michelle tab Chief scientific officer at
DIA sword molecular
Dr tab you may now begin your
presentation
okay thank you very much for that great
introduction and I'm so happy to be here
presenting with you all today uh let's
talk about what's happening right now
with the respiratory season especially
as we enter into this third year of the
pandemic and so with that let's go over
today's objectives so uh hopefully by
the end of my talk you will understand
the current trends and the respiratory
illness in this third year of the covet
pandemic will also take time to review
the theory of viral interference and
some other factors that can actually be
shaping the Resurgence of certain
respiratory viruses and then lastly we
will discuss why detecting and
differentiating respiratory pathogens is
really important for treatment and
isolation strategies
so in terms of the talks agenda today
we'll start by talking about respiratory
virus seasonality sort of how it was
before the pandemic and then the impact
the pandemic has had on virus
seasonality
and next we'll talk about a theory
called viral interference
we'll follow that with some Trends in
this current respiratory season uh
especially in the northern hemisphere in
the 2020 to 2000 2023 respiratory season
and then uh we'll talk specifically
about one of the big viruses of concern
that has surged and that is RSV or
respiratory synsticial virus
I'll also talk about some re-emerging
respiratory pathogens and then we'll end
by talking about Multiplex detection and
differentiation of respiratory pathogens
so let's Dive Right into respiratory
virus seasonality and then talk about
the pandemic impact you know what impact
has covid-19 had on what we would have
seen typically before the pandemic and
so this slide contains a figure here
that demonstrates that and so this
figure shows the typical seasonality
that we would see we have winter viruses
summer viruses and some that are present
all year long and so the winter viruses
that we know quite well in the northern
hemisphere at least we think of RSV
fluid and flu B and those are shown at
the top we have some viruses that we see
usually only during the summer time and
those include viruses like non-rinovirus
enteroviruses we also tend to see some
viruses all year long like human
metanooma virus or rhinovirus and then
some type specific viruses like para
influenza virus sort of come and go
depending upon the time of year and then
we have all your viruses like adenovirus
and human Boca virus and so that's the
typical seasonality at least up through
the pandemic but then the pandemic hit
and so now one of the big questions is
what will happen to the seasonality of
these viruses but then also what about
SARS Kobe 2 so now that things are
starting to come down calm down so to
speak will this end up also being a
seasonal virus and so I think we wish we
all had a crystal ball I think we don't
know that yet but let's talk about some
of the other things that we've observed
during the pandemic when there was such
high case counts of sarsko V2
so we'll start by talking about what we
saw in children less than two years old
and so this publication really
highlights that we saw the complete
disappearance really of certain
respiratory viruses like RSV influenza
melanoma virus and paraflus
in 2020 that's what happened
Disappearance in 2020-21 season we also
saw a reduction of other respiratory
viruses like Adeno Boca and enterovirus
but there were a couple where we saw
absolutely no significant difference in
the prevalence and that includes
rhinoviruses some of the non-sarce cov2
coronaviruses as well as other viruses
like CMV and so the chart on the left
shows that big drop so the bar goes up
and up until 2020 and then significantly
drops those are just the case counts in
the children less than two years old
there in 2021 season
[Music]
so one of the conclusions of this study
obviously is that we had a striking
reduction in hospitalizations in viral
cases and then in hospitalizations and
lower respiratory tract infections and a
modification of when these viruses were
showing up uh what time of year and very
interestingly it seemed that the
envelope viruses were mainly affected so
that could have been one of the clues
there and to why some viruses continue
to appear While others disappeared
so what happened with flu
and so uh on this particular slide is
data from the CDC and what I've done is
broken it into pre-pandemic influenza in
the U.S and then that's on the left in
the 2019 to 2020 season and then on the
right we have the
2022-2023 estimates based on the data
that's already come in through the end
of December of 2022 at the CPC and you
can see there that the case counts for
the 2019-2020 season were between 39 to
56 million total flu illnesses in that
particular season
flip over to the right hand side and we
are on par to have a season just like we
did pre-pandemic so flu levels have not
only come back but they've come back to
be just about basically where they were
before the pandemic showing up there at
about the 22 to 43 million
um case count estimates at least from
the CDC
but what about other viruses and
um this is flu once again on the left
hand side and it shows quite nicely this
data from the CDC that it was a lot of
testing in the 2021 season shown there
by the red arrow which is uh that shaded
blue part of the of this uh chart going
up but the black bar shows the total
number of positives for flu was
basically non-existent
um another virus here which is on the
right hand side of this chart para
influenza viruses they remained at a
very low rate less than one percent
positivity but by May 2021 their
prevalence also started to increase up
to about 10 percent you can see that bar
starting to go up that dark blue bar
shown there right above the red arrow
we saw RSV also drop to record lows
almost undetectable and that's shown on
the left hand side chart of course a lot
of testing for it
um but then you can start to see the
blue bar the Blue Line actually come up
with RSV cases and we certainly have had
an RSV surge occur so RSV Spike
Nationwide especially in the south of
the US and it happened sort of in an
unlikely season in the spring to Summer
of 2021 and that's this first uh Peak
that's seen on the left hand side of the
slot of the chart that's on the right
and then we had a low once again during
the summer time and then we have really
been walloped by a big RSV surge now
starting kind of early
um into the like the summer fall season
here in 2022 and we'll talk a little bit
more about RSV later in the talk
but what happened with the common cold
virus activity well it continued and
what I mean by common cold virus
activity is rhinovirus anterovirus and
adenovirus which continued to circulate
among children during the pandemic uh
non-sar scoby-2 coronavirus was also uh
were circulating although there was a
little bit of a delay there and so if
you look at these charts we have the
Rhino intro on the left we have the
adenovirus there present but at low
levels in the middle and then we have
this delay in the other non-sar
Scooby-Doo coronaviruses but you can see
the blue lines start to Peak up at the
end of 2021.
and so if we just look at all the data
all together the chart on the left kind
of tracks this so if we start from 2017
and we look at the comparison of percent
children positive for viruses over all
of these Seasons up at the top is RV EV
that's Rhino and entero you can see
there about 30 percent positivity uh in
kids over all of these Seasons up here
2021 but compare that to what you see
for RSV so before the pandemic rates at
16.7 percent or higher and then wow it
goes all the way down it drops to the
low of 1.2 percent the similar a picture
is there for flu which dropped to 2.6
percent and just other respiratory
viruses in general dropping down from
like that 14 15 down to 6.1 percent
so why was there this drift and what I
mean by drift is a shift in where we
started to see viruses come up again
um different from their typical Seasons
well of course the transmission
mechanisms were reduced we saw temporary
lockdowns in Virtual classes social
distancing PPE and of course reduced
travel those could have all been factors
causing this drift
but what about the persistence and here
is where I want to bring up the
non-envelope viruses like the rhinos and
the intros which persisted despite all
of these transmission mechanism control
uh mitigations that were in place well
non-envelope viruses actually stay for
prolonged periods of time on surfaces
they survive a lot longer than their
envelopes cousins and they're basically
less susceptible to prevention and
transmission from mask wearing or from
soaps or sanitizers and there's a lot
greater asymptomatic Transmission in
fact what's under appreciated sometimes
it's the amount of rhinovirus
asymptomatic transmission that there is
um globally and so
um these are just some theories about
why these Trends happened during the
pandemic
but when we think about when one virus
is dominant or present versus another
there are other mechanisms at play here
and so this slide lists some of those
mechanisms of respiratory viral
dominance so of course because of social
distancing travel Etc movement
restrictions we saw a lot of rest
typical respiratory viral activity and
transmission decrease
um and so it wasn't it was a it was a
hit across the board so to speak
but um then they've come back so of
course one of the questions is why
um but also for Respiratory dominance
here uh let's talk about flu
so interestingly historically when a
novel flu has emerged and has become
pandemic and sort of taken over the
planet whatever was circulating there in
the flu family beforehand basically
disappears and that pandemic strain
replaces that flu strain or those flu
strains that were circulating at the
lower levels and becomes the dominant
strain and uh this happened actually
um starting from H1N1 which was
circulating you know Spanish Flu early
1900s and then in 1957 it was replaced
by h2n2 and then in 1968
H3N2 replaced h2n2 and then in 2009 we
saw once again H1N1 replacing the H3N2
and when we see this for flu for example
that dominance of a respiratory virus it
might occur when the global population
has never seen that virus before in
terms of their immune system seeing it
what we call being immunologically naive
um and here is where a viral
interference or a temporary immunity
could be induced by that prevalent
predominant viral infection okay so
whereby one infection with a respiratory
fire is sort of limits the infection and
contribution
um from any other viruses that might
want to circulate and in fact
of course there are also seasonal
impacts on respiratory infections and so
we have you know the the impact of
um you know what is the temperature
outside what is the sunlight what is the
relative humidity and that goes for
inside and of course outside
um so absolute humidity and relative
humidity are both kind of important
factors and uh then as we move indoors
when there's Colder Weather then uh of
course relative humidity also comes into
play and if you've heard of droplet
theory um that's something else we need
to think about in terms of viruses and
their ability to transmit because the
amount of virus that's present in a
droplet how far those droplets can be
distributed how dry or wet the air is
that we're breathing of course all come
into play with how transmissible that
virus might be in those droplets add to
that if the weather's cold outside and
we have people coming together to
celebrate indoors together and so
certainly there's that social aspect the
contacts that people have in terms of
transmitting viruses to one another
there's also of course the factor of the
human host themselves and their immune
state which come into play here that can
also have an impact on respiratory
infections
the two major contributing factors are
the changing environments and seasons
and of course those human behaviors in
terms of transmission and seasonality of
some of these viruses
so that leads me to talk about something
that I already mentioned in more detail
and that is viral interference and this
is the theory that uh one virus can
basically cause an impact Downstream
that prevents infection from other
viruses and so when we typically think
about viral infections
um a lot of times we're thinking you
know one plus one equals two or maybe
even one plus one equals 10 depending
upon if we're talking about severity so
for example uh when someone's infected
right now with SARS cov2 and then they
do have a flu infection on top of that
obviously that infection can be
extremely severe so that is a positive
type of interaction even though it's not
positive for the patient it's positive
in terms of its severity
but viruses actually frequently
negatively interact and that is a
phenomenon known as viral interference
and this is when a primary virus
infecting a cell prohibits the infection
of that same cell by another secondary
virus or even by more viral particles of
that same viral type and so there's a
pictorial representation of that here in
the figure where we have a virus coming
in infecting a Cell moving over to the
right hand side now that infecting
infected cell basically gets uh some
body armor and deflects additional
infections by other viruses and so
that's sort of a basic and simple
principle here of what viral
interference is
if we could understand the mechanisms of
how this happens
um this might be a basis for developing
some new antiviral treatments and with
that let's talk about the historical
evidence for this actually occurring so
in the 1960s there were live virus
enterovirus vaccines that were used
in some clinical studies in children and
when those live entero vaccines were
used in those kids it was noticed that
there was decreased detection of
unrelated respiratory infections in
those kids after they had received those
injections and the reduction came into
in terms of reduction in flu cases in
those kids as well as paraflu RSV
rhinovirus and adenovirus infections in
in that study
in the 1970s there was a study in India
and Nepal that found that adenovirus
types tend to be prevalent in a
particular Village and there are no
other Adeno types circulating but that
one and even that one might differ from
Village to Village so there seemed to be
some kind of an exclusion happening even
amongst adenovirus types
there was a study performed in Norway
between 1974 and 1981 that analyzed the
respiratory infections in that country
and they showed that RSV and influenza
infections did not reach their epidemic
Peaks at the same time
now of course this seems a little
obvious to us now because we're always
used to now seeing at least pre-pandemic
a peak of RSV followed by fluway and flu
B but at least that analysis in Norway
showed that that kind of a pattern of
different viruses peaking at different
times has been present for a long time
and then in 2009 2010
we had pandemic H1N1 circulating the
globe and there was either was RSV
present at that time which basically
dropped down extremely low almost to
zero when pandemic H1N1 took over
and then there's a theory and some
evidence that rhinoviruses might have
interrupted the spread of that H1N1 flu
virus
um during that pandemic so Rhino
especially here I want you to remember
because
um there is a disruption there that
could have happened of flu
so if we look at other evidence there is
a lot of it this chart is just basically
meant to summarize all of that in this
paper from pareton actually looks at
what was the interfering virus that
impacted that second virus and you can
see the arrows there we have the
rhinovirus impacting the influence a
virus and then there is also evidence of
rhinovirus that is disrupting SARS cob2
infection and these evidences are coming
from different uh types of studies both
from epidemiological historical active
studies as well as cell culture and
animal models
so my question here
um and one of the questions that some
authors on some Studies have asked is
um if rhinovirus was seen to interfere
with the replication spread of pandemic
influenza virus as we saw in that
evidence back in the swine flu pandemic
2009-2010 could it do the same thing for
uh the current pandemic strain SARS cov2
and there's one key word there that's in
that question and that has to do with
interferon sensitivity so interferon is
a signaling mechanism that we'll talk
about in the next couple of slides and
there is evidence
um that this is actually what's
happening and so there was a study of
800 000 adult patients with cold
symptoms in the previous year before the
pandemic and it found that those
patients who had experienced cold
symptoms and let's assume that those
cold symptoms were from common cold
viruses like rhinovirus
those patients that had had a rhino
infection in the previous year leading
up to the pandemic were less likely to
test positive for SARS Kobe 2.
additional evidence has come from some
studies that have that by Tamira at all
that has shown that patients that had
had a rhinovirus infection before early
in the pandemic had a jump starting of
their interferon stimulated Gene
response their innate immune response
and that that response that interferon
response actually negatively impacted
Source Kobe 2 viral load in other words
if you had rhinovirus infection it
really limited the impact and actually
even replication of SARS Kobe 2
infection causing particles in patients
and so that's what we mean by viral
interference
so what causes viral interference well
I've already alluded to the interferon
response but there's also just some
basic direct competition between viruses
that can go on
let's talk a little bit more detail
about the interferon response and
there's a graphic here on the right hand
side of the slide that shows exactly
what is meant here so there's a viral
infection that virus goes into the cell
and it confers sort of an antiviral
state in that cell that's part of our
innate immune response the detection of
the viral RNA once the virus is taken
into the cell it causes infected cells
to secrete interferons and that's sort
of like a neighborhood watch system and
so that signaling system alerts other
surrounding cells if there's a viral
infection going on in this cell
that release also upregulates interferon
stimulating genes isgs and they encode
antiviral proteins that block virus from
entering cells black viruses from
leaving cells and shut off cellular
Machinery required for replication so a
virus gets in there starts hijacking the
cellular Machinery starts replicating
like crazy and then also the cell enters
this antiviral State at the same time
sort of deflecting other viruses and
maybe even preventing them from getting
in and conferring an advantage to that
first viral infection so there's a whole
Cascade of events that happen it's shown
in the graphic on the right hand slide
and I'm not going to go into detail on
that today
so interferon response could cause viral
interference there's also though this
just general direct competition between
viruses and the competition is of course
between cells to in fact sell surface
receptors if they use common receptors
cellular resources and back to
replication well faster replication the
faster hijacking of the cell wins the
battle so the first virus to win that
battle causes the cell to enter an
antiviral State and it really limits
that second viral infection
so the authors of this paper Chimera at
all have um looked into this especially
between rhinovirus and SARS Kobe 2 and
they have put out a model for this viral
interference uh and a quote from the
paper is the heterologist innate
immunity that is the interferon response
causes a subset of individuals who are
refractory to to infection during
periods of high respiratory virus
circulation so in other words if people
had a rhinovirus infection it conferred
this protection to them so even though
covid was circulating rampantly during
the pandemic there were certain
individuals who were protected from
getting that infection
so with that what are some future areas
of study and so certainly looking at
deficiencies in interferon production in
a patient or in individuals we want to
look into that to see if those
individuals are more if those with low
interferon responses are more prone to
getting co-infections or more severe
disease
or more severe clinical outcomes and
things like that due to co-infections
this will be the first winter in the
northern hemisphere where we're going to
actually start to see some co-infections
based on that data that I showed in the
first part of my talk since a lot of
viruses are coming back but it might
take several seasons for us to finally
see and observe the clear patterns that
are going to be taking place
viruses causing asymptomatic infections
could be key players in the spiral
interference and as I mentioned
rhinovirus causes a lot of these
asymptomatic infections and two
quotations I wanted to read that come
right out of the paper here so we have
Pablo Mercia from the Glasgow Center for
virus research and he said most of what
we know about virus infection virus
pathogenesis virus epidemiology it's
based on the one virus one disease
approach and that's not real and you
know it is not real because viruses are
circulating in our environments all the
time and even during covet although
covet was the most prevalent virus there
was still other viruses circulating and
certainly these have impacts on one
another the situation is much more
complex than maybe we would have
virtually thought
and then a quote here from Ellen foxman
from Yale anytime you have an expansion
of the Paradigm of how you understand
disease pathogenesis this opens up the
door to interventions that you've never
even thought of and so this leads me to
the next slide which is what about virus
interference used for infection
prevention and so many people are
starting to think about this General
interferon response and how we could
maybe use it in the future so that we
can study it and also develop antivirals
and so there was a paper that came out
early in the pandemic actually asking a
question can existing live vaccines
prevent covid this was based on the
theory that if you gave say oral polio
vaccine or any of the other live
vaccines because it's a live viral
infection an interferon responses
induced and so that General interferon
response but doesn't make somebody less
susceptible to subsequent viral
infections like by SARS Kobe 2. and so
there are some trials looking into this
exact thing right now we have live
vaccine trials against covid there's
five trials testing actually the
tuberculosis BCG vaccine in this way
there's two trials testing or a polio
vaccine and two trials testing that the
MMR the measles moms and rubella vaccine
looking to see you know once these live
attenuated vaccines are given challenge
those patients or track them to see if
they get subsequent infections at a
higher or lower rate than uh without
these kind of interventions and so we'll
have to wait and see what happens with
these kinds of interesting studies
so now let's switch to talk about the
trends in the current
2022-2023 respiratory season
and so let's begin with the influenza
update so what's happening right now
with flu so uh this is a snapshot as of
the end of December and this is based on
the CDC data and so what we have seen is
that we have had a large flu season
right we're back on pars we saw in the
beginning of my talk with what we saw
pre-pandemic the hospitalization rate
however is about four times higher than
the highest rate observed during this
same week and actually since like more
than 20 years ago
we've seen a lot of pediatric deaths and
um this is seems to be an age group or
there's more severe impact
we also see that we have more H3N2 than
H1N1 and we'll talk about that more in a
moment but you can see there that the
graph on the left at least the CDC
tracking is showing that we might have
hit our Peak an earlier season than
we've seen in the past but we might have
already hit our Peak and it's coming
down and but there's still a lot of hot
spots across the U.S and all of this
data does not include the post holiday
period reporting and so stay tuned and
keep we can keep checking in with the
CDC data to see what happens
post-holiday period
switching over to a similar update
that's provided on the European Union
from the ecdc and who joint influenza
update website and they saw something
extremely similar they continue to see
about 34 percent of specimens testing
positive for flu for the week ending
January 1st and just as we did in the
U.S it was an earlier we saw an earlier
influenza epidemic start than the
previous Four Seasons this was actually
predicted by what we saw in the southern
hemisphere as we know when we look at
things like flu we're always looking to
countries like Australia and their great
tracking to help us predict what's going
to happen in the northern hemisphere
they saw an early flu season they also
saw a big pediatric impact with more
severe illness in that patient
population and we're seeing the similar
things here in the northern hemisphere
okay
now let's hone in on what's Happening
specifically with influenza this season
and so of the influenza A type
circulating so far looking at October to
December we see about 30 percent are
H1N1 type and they're a specific type of
pandemic derivative strain called 6B 1A
5a2 and about 70 percent are H3N2
the good news is that the vaccine
strains are a very good antigenic match
to these particular viruses these fluid
viruses and also the good news is that
all viruses that have been collected and
tested thus far are susceptible to
influenza antivirals like acetamovir for
example you can see there on the right
hand side box that I've highlighted in
red there you can see that sort of 70 30
split in terms of the flu a strains that
are circulating so far this season in
terms of surveillance
so one note I wanted to make though is
that diagnostic test manufacturers need
to be diligent and alert for viral
mutations that may affect detection so
we have heard about some impacts on
certain tests that are available today
molecular tests for flu specifically
with the H1N1 strain that
6b1a5a2 strain and so you know one thing
is for certain flu will change it's an
RNA virus we have antigenic shift and
drift happening we constantly have
mutations that appear in that virus and
so at least for for our company where
I'm at so for diosorin molecular and
luminex we constantly are surveilling
the databases with the available
sequences that are out there for
influenza strains and other respiratory
viral strains and making sure that our
products continue to be able to detect
those strains despite sequence changes
and so at least on the DS4 and luminex
side of things we've already checked all
of our targeted testing products as well
as our Multiplex syn panel Target Target
products for to make sure that they can
detect this H1N1 strain that's
circulating now and I'm happy to report
that they all do but we as an industry
also need to keep up that kind of
vigilance to make sure that we're
continuing to detect and have that good
performance to catch these infections
so now carrying down a little bit
further on the slide let's switch over
to talk about what's happening with
influenza B so we do have influenza B
circulating again but what we have seen
are cases of the Victoria lineage there
are two different lineages Victoria and
Yamagata but why have that red arrow
there is pointing to the fact that there
has been no incidence of Yamagata
lineage flu bees detected so far this
season
and in fact flu B Yamagata has not been
seen since March of 2020 as I mentioned
these two types of strains or genotypes
of flu B typically alternate
predominance when one circulates we
might see some worse or more severe
illness in certain age groups versus
others but in general we have seen these
too and for the last couple of years
though we've seen a Dropout of flu B
so what has happened to this strain and
could it be extinct
um the answer is yes maybe uh and why
could it be extinct well it turns out
that there's some basic differences
between these two genotypes or strains
of flu B
we have a lower effective reproductive
number in the Yamagata lineage then we
do Victoria meaning it has a growth
Advantage we have no animal reservoir
for flu B so flua certainly we see that
in swine and also in birds as well as
humans and so there's always a reservoir
circulating keeping that virus you know
active on our planet but fluvy that's
not the case there's no animal Reservoir
so we also at the same time have a great
quadrivalent flu vaccine that covers you
know the H3 and the H1 types of flu a
but also has had Yamagata and Victoria
um vaccine coverage within it and so
we've also had very nice uptake of flu
vaccination and so high vaccination
coverage has induced that broad immune
protection and that kind of coverage can
lead to eradication of flu B
and the other thing that happened here
is that with the pandemic it coincided
with the time of Yamagata very low
prevalence and so all of these pressures
kind of evolutionarily at the same time
could have actually wiped out flu be
Yamagata so
um don't have a crystal ball but so far
and we can you can see they're the
annotations on the papers that have
talked about this it it could be extinct
and so let's cross our fingers that
we're able at least to wipe out this
particular strain of flu B
let's take a look really quickly at
Avian Influenza so uh while the pandemic
was happening all around the globe and
we started to see fluid cases come up
again and certainly RSV surging
um influenza was still circulating in
birds and Avian Influenza has always
been there there's been some really
great surveillance programs going on
from the CDC and the ecdc but they've
continued to take to detect h5n1 in wild
birds and poultry and that has been in
late 2000 2021 through 2022. luckily
there's only been two human cases one in
the U.S and one in the UK and looking at
the strain the risk of transmission to
the general public is extremely low and
I want to remind everybody the reason
for that is h5n1 you know it needs a
certain type of cell surface receptor in
order to gain access to cells and so
h5n1 is specialized in terms of the
cellic acid receptors that it can bind
to on bird cells okay it would need to
change to become adapted a better fit to
human cells to gain entry and cause a
pandemic and so it hasn't done that yet
and so that's why the risk of human
transmission is especially low but
people still work with birds and have
high exposure to it and so it's good to
know about it and because of that
there's monitoring programs you can go
on the CDC website you can see in their
surveillance how many wild birds how
much poultry and in humans where this
virus has been detected but there was a
story coming out and a warning just from
CDC in November you know we have a
record number of Avian Influenza
outbreaks right now on both wild birds
and poultry so certainly this is one to
just keep looking after
what else is happening well of course we
still have SARS Kobe 2 and covid
circulating the latest variance of
concern is
xbb.1.5 and it is rapidly transmitted
and it's starting to account for a
higher and higher number of new
confirmed cases in the U.S there are not
as many cases in Europe at least not yet
but of course these things can
constantly change especially after the
post-holiday period This is a relative
of xbb it's a recombinant of Omicron and
the ba 2.75 subvariant and as I
mentioned it's it has uh it's very
transmissible it seems to have a growth
Advantage it is not causing a major
surge in hospitalizations though and
that's the good news
um uh however the other good news I'd
say is that the bivalent booster that's
the Omicron booster so to speak it
affords really nice coverage of this
particular variant that's circulating
okay so that's that's all the that's the
good news is the bivalent booster the
bad news and maybe why we can expect a
lot of cases of from this variant there
has been very poor uptake of the
bivalent booster probably due to a lot
of different factors but here are the
statistics right from the CDC website at
least as of this first week of January
um so we have only about 38.1 percent of
people over age 65 who've had this
booster and only 15 percent of Ages 5
and Up And so there's a lot of people
who could be
um sort of under vaccinated so to speak
and not protected from Catching this
variant
and of course we have what's going on in
China we have uh the Chinese government
lifting the covered restrictions in
December uh early December they had a
very effective zero coveted policy they
actually only had reported about just
over 5 000 deaths but then they opened
up and they stopped these restrictions
and so with that there's been some
modeling that predicts that there could
be a huge amount of cases a huge surge
in China and a huge amount of deaths
maybe even over one million deaths we're
also not sure about the true reporting
and the numbers and of course we've had
countries that are extremely sensitive
to cases coming into them from China an
example is Northern Italy where was that
was the second Global hot spot in the
world in the SARS cov2 pandemic right so
um there was a story that came out in
December that
passengers were tested on tutor from
flights that arrived from China coming
into Milan and over 50 percent of
passengers on two of those
II positive and so now we've had
mandatory testing reimposed for people
coming from China into certain countries
right now and so
um we'll have to wait and see what
happens Here China has a very vulnerable
population their boosters are not
necessarily up to date even though there
was large vaccination campaigns
initially for the original versions of
SARS Kobe 2 and they have a large
elderly population as well and so this
is of concern for sure
what's up
okay we will switch now to talk about
another respiratory virus that has been
circulating that I've already mentioned
and that that is respiratory synthetial
virus and so this virus is an envelope
single-stranded RNA virus and it is a
major cause of global respiratory
illness and I think to some degree maybe
an underappreciated cause globally of
respiratory illness in a lot of
populations it's a mainly upper
respiratory pathogen and uh it but it
circulates in humans only this is
another case where there's not an animal
Reservoir there's two different types
fluid and flu B not fluid and flu B rsva
and rsvb
um but there are some high-risk
populations that I wanted to highlight
right now we see a lot of RSV in infants
and young children and that's usually
how people know about RSV but we also
see the elderly population the over 65s
that are especially vulnerable to RSV as
well
the most common cause of bronchiolitis
in globally is the RSV virus and it
circulates with ease especially in
places like day care centers and one
important thing to note also previous
infection with RSV does not convey
persistent immunity meaning you can get
this virus again and again and again
throughout your life
so as I already talked about what
happened during the pandemic well we saw
initially during the pandemic that there
was really no RSV but as soon as we had
pandemic restrictions opened up we saw
RSV come back and so over on the left
hand side as pointed out by the red
arrow we saw RSV returning in June of
2021 and then it went down again but now
starting from the summer of 2022 we have
this second with a second arrow is
increasing here with this red line here
we had this big surge in RSV cases
starting from the summer of 2022 and it
has now come down which is the the
graphic representation here on the very
right hand side we finally have started
to see it come down and so that is good
news for sure but it certainly was a big
burst of RSV so even when we think about
treatments and strategies right now I
mean there are some things available
most are for infants who are at high
risk like this FDA approved monoclonal
there's also a long-acting antibody body
shop for newborns which should cover
babies for the first six months of their
lives that's gotten FDA breakthrough
designation and also is already approved
in the EU in the European Union by the
European medicines Authority
um and there's some really interesting
things there under review now with at
FDA and this is because you know infants
especially babies they have really naive
immune systems and so just vaccinating
them with RSV is not a very good
protection strategy and so that really
opens the door here for what is an
effective strategy for vaccination and
that is a vaccination of pregnant women
and this is because they will elicit an
immune response and they will be able to
transfer those antibodies to their
developing baby this strategy has
actually been used for other infections
such as tetanus and whooping cough and
so it's something that we can really
look forward to hopefully making an
impact on the amount of RSV that's
circulating at least in that infant
population
but vaccination approaches for pregnant
women and then actually and for older
adults are also taking place and so
there's been a lot of recent progress
this is a little bit of history about
RSV vaccines
um in the 1960s there was a first go at
it but it failed actually there was an
enhancement of disease in the 2010 time
frame though there was a big development
at NIH when researchers determined the
structure of the RSV virus's two key
surface proteins the F and the g
proteins and that then allowed a lot of
focus to happen on those surface
proteins for Effective strategies for
vaccinations and there in the 2020s
there's several RSV vaccines and
clinical trials not just for pregnant
women as I mentioned but also for
seniors so we have Pfizer and GSK I'm
testing in both those populations we
have the Jansen J J and Bavarian Nordic
developing for adults over 60. moderna
is in clinical trials and late stage
trials for adults over 60. but vaccines
for children are much earlier in the
pipeline but at least we're seeing some
positive things and positive
developments and progress happening for
RSV vaccine these days
so let's switch to talk about some
re-emerging respiratory pathogens so
this goes beyond just talking about what
we hear about in the news all the time
which is the flu and the RSV for example
on top of SARS Kobe 2. you know other
non-influenza and non-rsp respiratory
viruses are also back we have seen the
non-source cov2 coronaviruses come back
we've also seen human metanumovirus come
back and Adeno as well as para influenza
1 has started circulating again
and so I want to hit on a couple of
viruses and that are maybe linked to
some reappearance and re-emergence
during the pandemic and that could be of
concern and so one of them is adenovirus
and so adenovirus is a big family of
viruses there are some that have caused
respiratory infections and there are
others that cause GI Illness but I
wanted to talk about one Adeno 41 here
that's associated with GI Illness but I
wanted to do so in context of the
pandemic and this is because during
2020-21 time frame we're sorry 2021 time
frame we saw worldwide about a thousand
cases of unexplained hepatitis in
children and 22 deaths and this was
reported by The Who in 2022. and uh it's
they were trying to find what was the
linkage here was this virus actually
causing the impacts and this hepatitis
and these children that they saw and how
could that be related to SARS Kobe too
well there was this publication that is
pretty recent in September 2022 and the
Journal of Pediatric gastroenterology
nutrition and it showed a link between
SARS Kobe 2 and Adeno and the authors
hypothesized that liver manifestations
they saw the hepatitis were because of a
post-infectious immune reaction
in patients who'd had SARS cov2 but now
that subsequently got an Adeno 41
infection and so I'm highlighting this
just to bring up the fact that we still
haven't seen the damage or whatever SARS
cov2 has caused in patients who've been
infected by it that had that will be
longer lasting and that still might show
itself once we get subsequent
respiratory or other types of infections
and one case here is Adeno 41.
switching over to a de facto respiratory
virus let's talk about enterovirus D68
or evd68 and so there certainly was an
increase in respiratory illness among
children adolescents in uh the last
Summer's time frame July to September of
2022 and the chart from the CDC at the
bottom there shows the arrow there in
red showing that peak of evd68 that was
seen and really there was very low
incidence of EVD 68 due to the pandemic
but in 2022 there were more acute
illnesses there were hospitalized
pediatric patients with severe
respiratory illness and those patients
were positive for rhino-entro sometimes
the tests can't differentiate but
certainly there was a lot of evidence
here that it was enterovirus D68
okay so let's switch to talking about a
different respiratory virus here
enterovirus D68 or ebd68 because it's
also of concern here because starting in
the summer time of 2022 we saw it come
back as well and so there's a chart
there on the left hand side from the CDC
and you can see the Red Arrow showing
the big peak and enterovirus cases that
have been seen and the big concern here
was that clinicians started noticing
more acute illness especially in a
pediatric populations associated with
infection and those were detections of
rhinovirus enterovirus because sometimes
some of the tests don't differentiate
within the spiral family but they
alerted these clinicians alerted the CDC
because there was this increase in
severe illness and why this happened was
likely due to this extended period of
low ebd68 circulation that could have
been because of the pandemic
but because of these concerns by
clinicians there was a CDC Health
advisory notice sent out a Han about
acute flaccid myelitis or AFM because
there has been an association seen
between ebd68 and AFM so what is AFM
it's a nervous system disease it's
characterized by rapid onset of weakness
in one or more limbs you know a la
poliovirus and as of January 4th of 2023
there's been 37 confirmed cases in 22
States just in this recent sort of
outbreak that has happened overall since
the CDC began their tracking many years
ago there's been about 716 confirmed
cases and you can see on the chart on
the right hand side these cases of AFM
coincide with the typical
every two year or so peak of introvirus
that is typically seen in the late
summer or fall months especially in the
Pediatric population and that's what's
shown here by these red arrows that I've
added to the chart art and the far right
hand side you can see that these cases
have started to come up again of course
maybe shifted a bit because of the
pandemic but still it's coming back and
so this is another virus that's
transmitted by the respiratory pathway
that we're going to want to keep our
eyes on
so another concern is group a strep
which we do think about as a respiratory
Illness but there's also been a CDC
recent Health advisory notice that's
gone out about an increase in pediatric
invasive group a strep infections and
this has not just been in the U.S
actually since September of 2022
European countries like Ireland France
and the Netherlands and Sweden as well
as the UK have reported an increased
number of cases of invasive group a
strep disease among children less than
10 years and actually even a couple of
deaths and we've seen several cases that
are several higher than in those
pre-pandemic levels so there is some
concern about this for sure and as I
mentioned we've also seen an increase in
the U.S the likelihood here is that it's
associated with this increased
circulation of respiratory viruses in
general and so of course when that
damage is done by respiratory viral
infection then we see a group a strep
coming in and it may increase the
severity of infection and be leading to
this risk of invasive disease one
particular note here you know we
continue to have some supply chain
impacts from the pandemic and also
because there's been so much respiratory
viral illness of late especially in
pediatric populations there's been an
academy American Academy of Pediatrics
notification that recently went out in
November there's been an amoxicillin
shortage and so this is really a
terrible time for that kind of a
shortage but you know is because there's
so much infection Happening Now
respiratory infection in pediatric
populations
another respiratory virus that I wanted
to mention and we should watch is
measles and this is because there have
been two recent outbreaks one in Ohio
One In Minnesota where we've seen a
great deal of cases and measles is
really a severe respiratory infection
yes it's vaccine preventable but you can
see the complications there at the
bottom of the chart but first of all how
it spreads it spreads of course person
to person in aerosols but it's one of
the most contagious respiratory virus
diseases
um it seems that um the the virus
lingers for hours or days following the
time that somebody could be around in a
room and so it's really easily spread to
different people who are in proximity
with somebody or even come into
proximity of areas somebody was in who's
had the virus one in five people can be
hospitalized with pneumonia
um and it can be really severe and cause
severe disease not only in children but
in adults as well especially
unvaccinated
um there's complications in pregnancy
you can have Encephalitis and also death
and you know the concern here is not
just as there's been some recent cases
but there has also been a trickle of
cases on and off from unvaccinated
populations right we've seen or heard
reports about some cases in Disneyland
and that's usually from Travelers coming
in from outside the U.S who are
unvaccinated but certainly
um these cases are of concern and one of
the big reasons they're of concern is
because there's been a pandemic impact
just on vaccination schedules and it's
estimated that like 25 million children
worldwide missed their first measles
vaccine dose through routine vaccination
in 2021 and even about 15 million more
missed their second dose and that's
according to the mmwr in November and
one thing with measles just like other
types of viruses we need herd immunity
in order to achieve this uh you know
protection of uh of people especially
those that are immunocompromised and
also to keep the virus at Bay and we
need 89 to 94 vaccine coverage to have
that for measles before the pandemic we
were already on the downside we were
already at 86 percent 2021 it was
estimated we're at 81 and so the wh on
CDC are deeply concerned about this
declining coverage rates of the measles
vaccine and there's a paradox written
there by the Hugh director The Who
director general you know the Paradox of
the pandemic is we put all this force
behind developing vaccines so quickly
for covid-19 but yet other vaccine
preventable illness that actually
sometimes still needs some you know
energy behind Global vaccination
campaigns such as measles have really
been forgotten and vaccinations have
been missed and so we really need to
keep our eye on this one and expect to
see more measles outbreaks in the U.S
and globally until we can improve this
vaccine coverage everywhere
and so with that look at kind of some of
the re-emerging
um and emerging respiratory viral
infections that are happening uh as we
come into this third year of the
pandemic and I want to switch to talk
about Multiplex detection
differentiation of respiratory pathogens
because I know that it's generally
accepted now that molecular methods are
actually a gold standard to detect
respiratory viral infections whether or
not there's just one virus causing on
the infection or if there are several
that are prevalent at the same time some
might have similar symptoms that need to
be sorted out because there are
different treatments based upon which
virus is detected and so
um here let's go through the CDC
guidance for clinicians when SARS Kobe 2
and influenza viruses are co-circulating
because there's some decision points
that should be made in different patient
populations for the approach to testing
using molecular multiplexing and when I
mean molecular multiplexing I mean
Standalone molecular tests I also mean
mini panels that maybe have two or three
viruses that cause similar symptoms but
I also mean molecular panels that could
be much bigger on the order of 16 20 25
viral and bacterial pathogens testing at
the same time those molecular syndromic
panels
and so in the case of this situation
here with the CDs cdc's recommendation a
patient presents to the outpatient or
emergency room
these symptoms for flu a flu B RSV and
covid they're extremely similar and hard
to differentiate and so we want to know
what the patient has and one of the
first decision points though is does the
patient require hospital admission so
even if the patient's going to be
admitted or not the recommendation is
still to collect respiratory specimens
and to order the testing for both flu
and Source Kobe 2 at least right now
while all those viruses are circulating
and if that kind of testing is not
available then even just switching over
to a standalone covid test initially is
recommended in the case that the patient
is probably not going to require
hospital admission
it's still kind of the same
recommendations because the signs and
symptoms of these predominant viruses
flu a flu B RSV and SARS cov2 are so
similar but here the record
recommendation for somebody who's not
likely to be hospitalized is test them
for SARS Kobe too and if they're
negative then other testing will depend
on the severity of their current
situation and what the doctor decides at
that time for infection control
but if we look at the bigger picture
here a lot of Hospital Laboratories and
systems have some general respiratory
algorithms depending upon if there's an
outpatient or inpatient scenario so that
emergency room visit initially could be
an outpatient type of scenario which I
have more in detail right here and many
institutions are testing those kinds of
patients with high throughput testing is
primary testing they might go to a
sample to answer system for overflow or
specific patient segments they're
interested in and uh basically they
usually have a primary system of testing
like covid flu a b or covid flu AV
altogether in a mini flex and then a
secondary backup system right and they
could use that maybe on some other
patient populations too of concern I
mean a compromised patients and elderly
patients or maybe even just pediatric
patients might all be getting syndromic
Multiplex larger panels and so the
algorithm depends on those patient
populations and the testing system
that's been implemented in that
particular Hospital
but switching to inpatients for a moment
there is kind of a different look at
that and that is because those
inpatients are more severely ill they're
usually under the care of an infectious
disease doctor perhaps they're
immunocompromised and so if you're in
season there you might do some primary
testing differently before you go to a
syndromic panel than you would off
season right so in season when there's a
lot of respiratory viruses circulating
you might take those more at risk
patients and immediately put them in a
full respiratory syndromic panel to make
sure that you've identified what's the
cause of the symptoms in that patient
immediately before you decide to do
anything else but if it's off season
maybe you're going to go to a targeted
test what are the most likely pathogens
causing the symptoms in that patient and
of course there's the in season and off
season type of a scenario too that was a
thing pre-pandemic we'll see how things
end up as we come out of the pandemic
and what hospitals decide to do but that
leads me to be able to be able to talk
about out the kinds of testing both
miniplex Standalone and Multiplex
syndromic panel molecular testing that
we have available from diazorin
molecular and from luminex and so our
sample answer systems for targeted or
Mini Plex testing are shown at the top
the Aries and also the liaison MDX
systems offer covet Standalone also flu
a b RSV testing as well as some new
combination testing we have our
simplexacovid19 flu a b direct kit under
review at FDA right now and we have our
Aries flu AB RSV and covet assay under
review at FDA net right now as well so
that's targeted or Standalone mini panel
testing but if we switch to the
syndromic panels we also have some
offerings we have the varogene
respiratory pathogens Flex test
available that has about 17 to 18
targets available on it for flexible
testing and we also have the next tag
family of products that can be run on
the magpix and so that includes the next
tag RPP plus SARS Kobe 2 that has
emergency use authorization and includes
the SARS cov2 Target and so we have some
flexibility that can be offered
depending upon the systems and that can
meet the needs of the different
scenarios of the different hospitals or
Laboratories depending upon those
inpatient or outpatient types of
workflows that I showed in the previous
slides
and so with that I'd like to summarize
that the covid-19 pandemic has
definitely impacted the typical
respiratory season RSV and flu have
returned but they're sure our shifts in
seasonality and some viral lineages have
disappeared like flu B Yamagata there's
factors like viral interference that
might have been a factor in the seasonal
shifts and it could lead though that
understanding that more could lead to
novel antiviral strategies but vigilance
is needed for things like evd6a vaccine
preventable viruses like measles and
even for things like the invasive group
a strep but having the appropriate tests
whether they're targeted or Multiplex
syndromic or Standalone to allow for
that flexibility to meet the needs of
testing of patients is really a benefit
for accurate diagnosis for diagnosing
the pathogens causing that respiratory
illness and so with that I wanted to
thank you very much for your attention
today and I welcome any of your
questions
thank you Dr Tabb for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
non-coveted respiratory illnesses are on
the rise with many causing outbreaks in
the U.S what are the mitigating
strategies the industry is taking to
help respond to these surges
okay thank you um that is a really
excellent question so um I'll answer
from the perspective of geosorin
molecular and luminex so first of all
you know we don't have a crystal ball
but we've seen these surges and so we
have uh increased our raw material
supplies on hand so that we can respond
to these increases of course we are
going to continue our surveillance to
watch the numbers so that we can
increase our production of kids for
example and step with those increases
that we see in terms of surveillance I
would also say that uh you know we
should as I mentioned keep our eye on
the strains and continue to make sure
just in general as an industry that as
these new viruses pop up or different
variants of viruses pop up that our
products continue to detect them and the
performance is still good
okay thank you our second question here
the covid pandemic has disrupted typical
seasonal Trends in RSB infection rates
now that covet's specific infection
prevention measures have largely been
retracted is the expectation that RSV
Trends will return to normal
also a really good question
um you know so I think
historically at least in the northern
hemisphere as I mentioned we always
would see RSV come before fluid and flu
B
but um and certainly it's back but it
came back a little off season a little
early a little bit of a shift so I think
one of my questions is you know why is
RSV seasonal where it's at to begin with
what are the other things about that
virus that we don't may not understand
yet like those features like you know
the droplet theory or viral interference
that impact exactly when in the season
or seasons of the year it shows up and
so
um it's definitely back it's definitely
circulating now
um but where it ends up if it'll go back
to traditional you know space there
right in that late fall or early
respiratory season and in the northern
hemisphere that'd be like the November
time frame
um only time will tell
um once again wish I had a quick crystal
ball to predict that but that's just my
view on on your question
fantastic it looks like we have time for
one more question is there a concern
given recent measles outbreaks in the
U.S that other vaccine preventable viral
infections such as mumps or rubella are
also at risk of sudden outbreaks
also an excellent question uh I think
the answer there is yes
although measles is the most highly
transmissible of those
um you know still the fact that
vaccinations are have not been up to
date the fact that vaccinations were
really impacted just those usual doctors
visits those well-baby visits for
example were really impacted by the
pandemic and so I think that there's
just great concern in general and there
needs to be you know better vaccination
campaigns within the U.S globally to
help protect everyone because we maybe
people have forgotten about how bad some
of these vaccine preventable illnesses
were long ago because we've all lived in
the ages of the age here of when we have
vaccines to prevent these illnesses or
these viruses been circulating and so
um yeah I hope people really
um you know get the energy behind the
spirit behind Global vaccination
campaigns that we we don't have to see a
return of some of these vaccine
preventable illnesses so
great question
perfect thank you Dr tap do you have any
final comments for our audience
um just stay healthy stay vigilant and
uh and you know let's continue to try to
uh you know uh probably you know be
hygienic too I'd say uh wash your hands
don't touch your eyes nose or mouth
without washing your hands just the
typical preventions that we can all have
here to keep us from getting respiratory
viral infections
stay healthy
thank you again Dr Todd for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor diasaurin molecular for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye